llegó el momento de repasar la
información económica en france 24 para
ello contamos una noche más con nuestro
compañero jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
y vamos a empezar como viene siendo
costumbre ya con la las consecuencias de
la guerra en ucrania aquí en américa
latina' ahora dice la agencia de
calificación crediticia moody's que la
guerra en ucrania afectará aumentando la
inflación y frenando el crecimiento de
latinoamérica en un reciente informe la
agencia afirma que aunque la relación
económica y financiera de latinoamérica
con rusia y ucrania es limitada la
región va a sufrir el aumento de los
precios de la energía asimismo prevé que
la guerra afecte el acceso a las
materias primas agrícolas e industriales
creando más inflación y el
endurecimiento de la política monetaria
la agencia también espera que las
presiones inflacionarias se moverán en
la segunda mitad del año aunque advirtió
que la inflación se mantendrá muy por
encima de los objetivos de los bancos
centrales el aumento de los precios de
las materias primas podrá beneficiar a
países productores como brasil chile
colombia y perú aunque incrementarán los
costos de los insumos para el transporte
asimismo pronostican que aumentarán los
costos de la agricultura esto por la
erupción de las exportaciones de
fertilizantes de rusia que son
importantes para américa latina y
especialmente para países como brasil
bueno pero estas consecuencias ya se han
empezado a sentir por ejemplo en perú
donde llevan varios días de protestas
por el aumento de los precios y es que
luego de esta medida que promulgó el
presidente pedro castillo y que desató
las críticas de varios políticos
incluidos sus antiguos aliados castillo
se decidió por retractarse a esta medida
de los altos precios del combustible
provocaron que el 28 de marzo el gremio
de transportistas de carga anunciarán un
paro indefinido y en algunas regiones
las protestas se tornaron violentas los
limeños fueron sorprendidos por la
medida para lima y su vecina provincia
de callao el presidente argumentó que el
'toque de queda' buscaba resguardar la
seguridad de la población la
confederación nacional de instituciones
empresariales privadas que es la
principal patronal de perú estimó que la
medida representaría una pérdida de unos
270 millones de dólares la patronal dijo
que la medida fue desproporcionada y
aseguran que tendrá un grave impacto
económico y social sobre todo para los
trabajadores pymes y emprendedores esta
medida también afectó al menos a 10
millones de personas durante este día y
cambiamos eeuu porque allí la aerolínea
jetblue hice una oferta para comprar
para comprar a su rival spirit si la
cifra asciende a 3.600 millones de
dólares para hacerse con su rival spirit
dijo que recibió una propuesta no
solicitada por parte de jetblue para
hacerse con todas sus acciones por un
precio de 33 dólares por título spirit
te aseguro que la junta directiva de la
empresa trabajará con sus asesores
financieros y jurídicos para evaluar
esta propuesta y optar por la opción que
más se interese a la compañía y a sus
accionistas la noticia hizo que las
acciones de espíritu aumentaran un 22
por ciento hasta los 26 dólares por
acción spirit y frontier anunciaron en
febrero pasado un acuerdo para crear la
quinta mayor aerolínea de eeuu y
prometieron crear un verdadero
competidor para los cuatro gigantes de
estadounidense american airlines delta
united y software y bueno cambiamos
ahora la famosa lista forbes que ha
actualizado esta lista de súper ricos en
ahora unas 236 personas que se estrenan
en la lista entre ellos rihanna y peter
jackson en la lista hay 87
multimillonarios - y su patrimonio vale
400 mil millones de dólares menos que
hace un año aunque pese a la guerra la
pandemia y la volatilidad de los
mercados hay 236 personas de 34 países
que se estrenan como multimillonarios
china aportó 262 nuevos multimillonarios
convirtiéndose en el país con la mayor
cifra eeuu el segundo país con más
nuevos miembros 50 en total sólo 33 de
los 236 recién llegados a la lista de
multimillonarios de force este año son
mujeres de ellas quien posee la mayor
fortuna hecha por sí misma es melanie
perkins de 34 años con fundador y
consejera delegada de camba carlos slim
el magnate de las telecomunicaciones
mexicano continúa como la persona más
rica de latinoamerica y se sitúa en el
puesto número 13 del listado de las
mayores fortunas del mundo la estrella
del pop rihanna es la primera
multimillonaria de barbados en ingresar
a esta lista mientras que el director de
el señor de los anillos peter jackson se
hizo multimillonario en noviembre cuando
vendió una participación de su tienda de
efectos gráficos digitales qüetta jorge
no sé si tú y yo saldremos algún día en
esta lista vamos ahora con los
indicadores de las bolsas
internacionales empezamos con what's ri
que cerró en negativo tras los
comentarios de los representantes de la
reserva federal de eeuu que apuntan a
una política monetaria más agresiva en
europa las acciones subieron el martes
mientras los inversores esperaban una
serie de nuevas sanciones contra moscú y
en américa latina' el índice es anti
merval de la bolsa de comercio de buenos
aires cerró con una bajada del 15 por
ciento muchísimas gracias por este
repaso a nuestros espectadores sigan con
nosotros
[Música]